in Guinea's Capital kri an
uncontrollable Inferno rages through the
Port City from a short distance those
who escaped watch their homes and
belongings go up in Flames their
relatives are trapped in the flames and
cannot be rescued the fire is
spreading I was going to bed when I
heard an enormous noise so loud it blew
the roof off the ceiling crumbled I ran
from my house there was dust everywhere
and I could see the Flames everybody was
running
out the blast in the country's main oil
Depot came shortly after midnight the
heat could be felt several kilometers
away in the suburbs waking many of the
1.6 million people living in the capital
Panic
spreads firefighters battle the Flames
with all the equipment they have but
it's not
enough we've been here since 2:00 in the
morning trying our best to do our work
and bring this fire to an
end in a statement the government calls
for calm it says the cause of the blaze
is unknown workers are asked to stay
home schools are shut along with petrol
stations as authorities try to control
what seems an uncontrollable fire
Nicholas Hawk Al jazer